Dr. Peterson,
I'm really hoping you can share your
thoughts on the day.
Just shooting.
Yeah.
Well,
what I would do is recommend the
biblical lecture I did on Cain and Abel,
I would say,
because I think that that's a good
summary of the state of mind that
somebody has to be in in order to do
what was done at Los Vegas.
So you have to be very,
very embittered by life in order to do
that sort of thing.
And you have to be searching for
revenge,
I would say.
And it's not,
you know,
you might think,
well,
it's only revenge on other people
because you've developed hatred for
people,
but it's deeper than that.
It's not just hatred for people.
I would say it's hatred for being itself
and,
and the desire to take revenge on being
for the outrage of the tragedy and
suffering that's associated with being,
um,
and maybe the tragedy and suffering
that's being part and parcel of your own
life.
And that makes you embittered.
And then past embittered becomes
outraged and past outrage becomes well
homicidal or even genocidal.
And that's a terrible state of mind to
begin.
It's a hellish state.
Um,
I believe that the best way to
conceptualize the state of mind that
someone has to be at in order to do
something like the Columbine shootings
for example,
or what happened in Las Vegas is that
you're really an,
now you have to speak about it and
religious languages.
You're really out for revenge against
God,
for the outrage of creation.
That's what it looks like to me.
And that's a state of mind that's truly
hellish and you could get there by
broody long enough.
Now it's also possible,
I mean this guy didn't have any previous
history,
criminal history or anything like that
and he's pretty old.
So you know,
there's also also also the possibility
of some kind of neurological pathology
that that might be characteristic of
him.
You know,
some degenerative neurological disease.
There was a kid years ago at the
University of Texas at Austin who
climbed up on the tower there and shot a
number of people with a high powered
rifle and he had a fast growing tumor on
his hypothalamus and had reported like
these being overcome with extreme
feelings of rage.
And so that's another possibility.
But I would say the,
uh,
embitterment hypothesis is the strongest
one.
I would also say too,
I noticed the Steven Pinker tweeted this
today,
is that one of the ways of controlling
this sort of thing would be for the
press to agree,
not for there to be a blanket agreement,
not to publicize the name or any other
identity markers of the people who do
the shooting.
Because there's also this really,
what would you call it?
Arrogance.
It's a kind of arrogance and pride last
ditch,
arrogance and pride that that is
associated with the fantasies that drive
this sort of behavior.
And the fantasy is like,
well,
after I do this,
everyone will sure know the who,
who the hell I was.
You know,
even though maybe I was ignored or
unhappy when I was alive after I'm dead,
everybody's going to know who I was and
what idea did you know?
So there's this underground desire for
fame,
I guess it's notoriety,
but notoriety might be preferable to
being ignored.
And so,
you know,
there's a lot of talk about gun control
and that's understandable,
especially with regards to automatic
rifles.
Um,
although I also understand why the
people who are gun owners are afraid of,
of,
um,
allowing what they regard as one of
their fundamental rights to be infringed
upon.
But it would certainly be useful if we
stop giving people who do this sort of
thing,
not $100 million worth of free publicity
and all the notoriety they can manage.
So,
you know,
that's another way of thinking about
controlling it.
So
yeah,
one of the things you'll see if,
if,
if you're interested in this sort of
thing,
if you ever go read the writings of,
of the Columbine killers that the teens,
they're very interesting.
They're very much worth reading,
especially I think it's Dylan Klebold
who was the more literate of the,
of the two.
But he tells you exactly where he went
after brooding and brooding and brooding
on his,
his isolation and segregation from
mankind.
So he's out there beyond,
he's out there in a chaotic domain and
because he's tortured by that,
his thoughts taken unbelievably dark
turn,
like it's unimaginably dark.
Um,
if you're interested in that sort of
thing,
you could read that.
There's another book you could read
called Pans,
Ram,
p,
a,
N,
zed,
r,
a,
m.
And it's a fascinating book.
It's about this guy who I think he raped
1200 men.
So that sort of tells you what sort of
guy he was extraordinarily physically
powerful and brutal and malevolent.
And he was kind of a juvenile delinquent
type and they put them in a reform
school and he was not well treated it.
Now in reform school,
it's sorta like the worst of the
Canadian residential schools.
And when he came out,
he was not a happy boy.
And so he spent the rest of his life
trying to be as destructive as he could
possibly imagine and purely consciously
with malevolent intent.
And then,
and,
and believe me,
he was pretty destructive.
He kept track of the dollar value of all
the buildings he burned down.
He tried to start a war between Britain
and the United States.
Like he was an all out for all out may
ham,
his dying words,
they are going to hang him.
Um,
he told the guy who was going to hang
them too.
He said,
hurry up you who's your bastard?
I could kill 12 man in the time it takes
you to hang me.
And that's exactly the sort of person he
was.
And he made friends with this physician
in the,
in the prison who he thought was like
the first person who ever did something
nice for them,
gave them a dollar for cigarettes if I
remember correctly.
And the physician encouraged him to
write his autobiography.
And so we did.
And it's available.
And so if you want a view,
because you know you,
you always think of people,
you think well people have good
intentions,
you know that you specially things out
if you're naive and agreeable.
So all of you who are sitting there out
there thinking people have good
intentions,
you're probably high in agreeableness,
but that's not always the case.
People can have very dark motivations
that are fully conscious and very well
elaborated and pans around was no,
he was smart and his book is very well
written and he tells you exactly why he
thought the way he thought.
And so it's a good glimpse of exactly
this sort of thing where you can get to
if you want to buy brooding on your
specific misfortune.
You know,
in his,
his basic credo was that human beings
were so reprehensible that they should
just be eliminated and believe me,
that's what he was trying to do.
And these people who do terrible things
like the Columbine shooters,
that's exactly what,
for lack of a better word,
they're possessed by it's sheer
malevolence.
And the Columbine kids had a much more
spectacular catastrophe plan than the
one that actually occur.
And they knew it was going to be a full
blown media circus.
And lots of these people who engage in
these sorts of mass murders,
they know about the other mass murderers
and they're engaged in a competition.
And the competition is who can do the
most brutal thing the fastest,
something like that.
So you can't just be thinking about
people who've,
you know,
who have good intentions,
but if somehow gone wrong,
if you ever meet someone who isn't like
that and you think that you're just a
tree with ripe fruit to be plucked.